Some see it as the ultimate selfless act
Emma was potentially losing her life...
...on the table
But surrogacy—carrying a child for someone else...
...is also a fast-growing global trade...
...one that’s transforming ideas about family
The legal definition of family is changing over time
What’s driving this boom...
...in the baby business?
I’ve done, I believe, over 8,000 surrogate cycles in my career
...outlawed and hated in many countries
The inside of a woman’s body...
...is being used as a workplace
How can surrogacy be better policed...
...and its children better protected?
Good morning
Hi, how are you?
I’m feeling excited, a little bit nervous
Jessica has signed up...
...to provide the gift of life
This is just giving us permission...
...to place the embryo into your uterus
Just print, sign and date right there
Jessica is a surrogate
And she has no genetic link to the embryo...
...which is about to be implanted into her
I love being able to help someone...
...to be able to have a family...
...that they’re not able to on their own
Gestational surrogacy, as it’s known...
...is now significantly more common...
...than surrogates using their own eggs
Jessica’s doctor, David Smotrich...
...is one of its leading practitioners
Those of us who do a lot of surrogacy...
...find that gestational surrogacy is a better approach...
...and it makes it much easier in terms of everybody involved
The genetic makeup of the child is something that is very...
...very concerning for the overwhelming...
...majority of couples that we work with
Jessica has had to pass stringent...
...medical and psychological vetting procedures
Who is driving you home today?
My husband will be picking me up
Okay
And most Californian agencies...
...require surrogates to be mothers already
For my kids, I’ve always told them, “Mom’s babysitting”
So they have always known that...
...the baby that I’m carrying is not ours
So we’re going to take you back...
...and just get started, okay?
Showtime!
All the testing that we’re doing on her and her body...
...actually is for another couple
All righty!
It’s nice that they’re awake!
That couple are Nima and Hamish
Based in Australia, they are the “intended parents” as they’re often called
In Australia, it’s very difficult to adopt
Surrogacy sort of felt like really the only...
...reliable option in terms of having a child
The embryo implanted inside Jessica...
...was made using Nima’s sperm...
...and an egg from an American donor
Hello!
Jessica has already given the couple a son, Hugo
Now they’re hoping she’ll add a baby girl to the family
Jessica, are you ready?
I’m ready
Okay, you’re going to feel my fingertips first and then speculum
Okay? Here we go
California...
...so often at the forefront of new technologies...
...has become the surrogacy capital of the world
I’ve done, I believe, over 8,000 surrogate cycles in my career
We’ve helped couples in over 100 different countries...
...become families
If you look at the screen behind me...
...we’re going to show you...
...the actual embryo that we are going to transfer
Back in 1998...
...David was one of the first doctors to help same-sex couples...
...become parents through surrogacy
This is my trial catheter
Okay, I’m covering you up
Some may say you can’t put a price on having a family
But here in California, they do
Intended parents usually pay between $110,000...
...to upwards of $200,000 for surrogacy services
And surrogates like Jessica...
...can earn between $30,000 and $60,000
Do you want to stop and make your appointment for Monday?
Yes
When you’re a first-time surrogate...
...you obviously don’t know if IVF is going to work for you
So as you go on to a second one, the pay increases...
...because obviously they know that you can carry this baby...
...with no issues
Think about everything that we are putting our body through...
...to be able to have this baby
For Nima, the transactional nature of the relationship...
...with Jessica is part of the appeal
I see it as a win-win
She is doing something amazing for us...
...able to earn some money through it...
...to help her own family and has made the decision herself
Bye bye!
The number of children born to surrogacy globally is unknown
Data only exist for some countries, such as Britain
And this shows a small but increasing number of parental orders...
...transfers of custodial rights from surrogates to intended parents
But globally, the surrogacy industry was estimated to be worth...
...over $14bn in 2022...
...a figure that may rise as high as $130bn...
...over the coming decade
Same-sex couples wanting children...
...are one of the key drivers of this growth
In Britain, for example, about half of all intended parents are gay
The legal definition of family...
...is changing over time
Which means that the definition...
...of family is now accepted...
...as being more than just the...
...you know, mum, dad and 2.5 children
But there’s another, perhaps more significant factor...
...making the surrogacy business grow
Declining fertility rates amongst the heterosexual population
Women are now choosing to start families later in life...
...and this carries a higher risk of infertility
The World Health Organisation recently...
...produced a report that said up to...
...17.5% of people will be affected by infertility in their lives
So that’s one in six people
So if you are infertile, if you have a burning desire...
...to have a family, you generally have tried everything else...
...you’ve tried IVF, your last resort is surrogacy
The surrogacy industry has also benefited from celebrity limelight
As the Paris Hiltons of this world keep up with the likes of Khloe Kardashian
When I went to the hospital, I really think that was the first time...
...that it really registered
You’re like, “Okay, we’re having a baby!”
Even if such famous parents are usually living...
...in a different financial reality from most
Well, it might be inspiring...
...and it’s news
It’s certainly not the norm for most people going through these processes...
...who haven’t got the money or the status
What’s especially striking about the surrogacy business...
...is how globalised it’s become
Here’s why
Relatively few countries allow surrogates to be expressly paid...
...for the labour of carrying a child
For example, Georgia, Ukraine and certain states in America
However, this kind of commercial surrogacy...
...is against the law in many more countries...
...like China, Germany, Turkey, France...
...and Italy
That means residents of these countries wanting a surrogate have to look abroad...
...to countries where surrogacy is allowed
The transnational business of surrogacy is very fluid
Originally, India was a popular destination
The Indian government then said, “No, we’re not going to allow foreigners...
...to come in and use our population for surrogacy”
And it was shut down in Thailand
Then it went to Laos
We’re seeing an increasing trend for countries in Europe particularly...
...to turn their laws against surrogacy...
...and to forbid their citizens from engaging in it
Opposition to surrogacy often comes from the religious right...
...and conservative politicians
In Italy...
...one politician has even compared surrogacy to child abuse
It’s a serious crime, in my opinion more serious than paedophilia
On the other side of the political spectrum...
...radical feminists are often equally opposed...
...if for different reasons
It’s a financial trade...
...therefore, there’s huge amounts of exploitation...
...because the inside of a woman’s body is being used as a workplace
It’s not just hostility and laws...
...which push intended parents to seek surrogates overseas
It’s hard economics, too
For those unable to afford services in America...
...other countries offer lower-cost alternatives
In Greece, prices start at around $88,000...
...while in Georgia, it’s less than half that...
...although in 2024, foreigners will be banned from surrogacy services there
Before the Russian invasion...
...Ukraine was a global surrogacy hub...
...offering affordable prices to customers from rich countries
Ukraine, almost by accident...
...had laws...
...that allowed foreigners to be named on the birth certificate
There was a large number of high-quality IVF clinics popped up
It also has a very large population...
...so there was no shortage of surrogates...
...to meet that demand
There are babies from America, Italy, Spain...
...Britain, China, France and Germany, as well as from Bulgaria
Before the war, Ukrainian surrogates were producing over 2,500 babies...
...each year, mostly for foreigners...
...with half of that demand coming from China...
...where surrogacy is banned
The war has since reduced demand...
...although it’s also forced aspiring parents to take unusual measures
People will go to extreme lengths to be united with their child
Wealthier returning parents were engaging...
...security teams with armoured vehicles...
...to take them into Ukraine, into Kyiv...
...to pick up their baby and take them out
The rise in IVF...
...cheap air travel and online marketing...
...have all allowed low-cost surrogacy agencies to expand across the world
But there is a dark underbelly to this industry
In countries as widespread as Guatemala, Laos and Kenya...
...surrogacy is neither banned nor permitted under law
In these places, the industry is unregulated...
...and raising concerns
The surrogacy industry, it’s really growing...
...and it’s growing so fast
Naipanoi Lepapa is a journalist in Nairobi...
...who exposes the human cost of failing to regulate surrogacy
If you use surrogates in my country...
...there are no laws around this practice
This means surrogates are not protected and some are exploited
I have met surrogates who have been intimidated...
...who have been forced to have abortions...
...and then they are defrauded out of their money
In a country where 27% of the population lives below the poverty line...
...of just over $2 a day...
...agencies prey on vulnerable and illiterate women in slums...
...like this one in Dandora
Naipanoi discovered one victim...
...who miscarried at five months...
...but was left with the dead foetus inside her for days...
...and left crippled for life
Instead of immediately removing the foetus...
...the agent told her he’s going to look...
...for someone who is going to operate on her
So it took a whole week
She’s always in pain, she can’t do anything
She’s still struggling
To add insult to injury...
...this surrogate was never even paid
You only get paid when you produce a baby...
...but when you miscarried, you’re not paid anything
Naipanoi is on her way to meet another victim
Today I’m meeting a woman...
...who says she was asked for sex in exchange for work...
...as a surrogate
This woman agreed to be filmed...
...provided her identity is protected
Some surrogates have said that they have been asked for sex
Did it also happen to you?
Yes, it happened to me, yes
And I came to realise that that man...
...is sleeping with almost every girl
Since I had no option...
...I did it because he was promising me...
...he was going to shape my life
She was recruited as a surrogate through Facebook...
...and was promised a life-changing $4,500...
...roughly two years’ earnings
But she was given no medical advice
They didn’t ask me to sign anything...
...before the embryo transfer...
...so I was not concerned about all those things
All I was praying for is that the process goes through well...
...and I get pregnant so I can get the money
It is considered good practice to transfer only one embryo...
...to reduce the risks to both mother and baby
This woman endured the transfer of four embryos...
...without choice
Three of the embryos implanted successfully...
...and rather than risk triplets, the agency chose to abort one
She was later forced to have a Caesarean section...
...to deliver twins...
...and is still owed over half her money
They operated on me
I felt like running away
I’ve never experienced that kind of pain
I couldn’t move, I couldn’t do anything
Why do you think CS [caesarean sections] are performed on surrogates?
They don’t care about surrogates
They just want to remove their babies
Life is much riskier for surrogates in poor countries like Kenya...
...where for every 100,000 births...
...an estimated 530 women die
By comparison, in the EU, that figure is just 6
The surrogacy market within poor countries is often driven by foreign demand
So what, if anything, can be done to address this...
...global problem of exploitation of surrogates?
Banning surrogacy is not the answer
Just as human rights law says, you cannot tell a woman...
...that she has to have an abortion or that she can’t have an abortion...
...the same principles apply to surrogacy
It is the individual woman’s choice...
...whether and how she uses her reproductive system
Perhaps a better idea would be to make surrogacy legal...
...and well regulated in more places
The fact that surrogacy is such a transnational business...
...is very problematic
It will be much better if countries could come to terms...
...with the fact that their nationals do require surrogacy...
...and they could put laws in place in their own countries...
...to allow much easier access to surrogacy at home
In Britain...
...one survey found that two-thirds of intended parents...
...chose to go overseas for surrogacy...
...because they felt laws were unfavourable to them at home
After birth, it can take half a year...
...or more for intended parents to become legal guardians of their surrogate children
How many shirts are you bringing?
Erm...three?
Campaigners like Alan White and his partner Nic...
...have contributed to law reforms that will make this process quicker
Alan is chair of the board of SurrogacyUK...
...a non-profit advocacy and support group
The law changes will make things more secure...
...for all parties involved in surrogacy
Surrogates, under the current law...
...they are the legal parents of a child born through surrogacy...
...so actually, they carry a tremendous amount of risk in the process
Oh what’s up with you?
It is a bit bonkers in comparison to other people’s experience...
...that you wouldn’t expect someone to turn up...
...when your child’s six months old...
...and decide whether you can keep him or not
What was that?
Broccoli
Are you messy?
The couple are about to take their surrogate-born child, Jago...
...on holiday for the first time
Let’s go, let’s go, let’s go
But even though he is five months old, Jago is still legally not their child
Don’t eat your feet
I think you look nice
Until a parental order is granted by the courts...
...in legal terms, Jago’s surrogate, Emma, will be left holding the baby
So you’d sit him between your legs and need to put some toys in front of him
I knew I was legally his parent, and I knew that my husband...
...he would have to go on the birth certificate...
...which is completely not right either
In Britain, surrogates like Emma cannot be paid...
...but can receive pregnancy-related expenses
It’s sometimes known as the altruistic model...
...and in Emma’s case...
...it may be hard to find a worthier example of that term
I ended up delivering Jago, and then immediately after...
...bled quite a lot, so I had to be rushed to theatre
After the birth, Emma had a big postpartum haemorrhage
The room suddenly filled with 20 medical staff...
...crash trolleys, all the stuff that you don’t want to see
Emma was potentially losing her life on the table
The midwifery team started talking to Emma about having to do things...
...to save her life, and it was horrible
Emma’s six children and her husband nearly lost her
All so that Alan and Nic could become parents
There’s no way you can thank someone for that...
...you just can’t
There just aren’t the words
Holding him for the first time and realising that this is your child...
...that you’re responsible for his happiness, and...
...it’s amazing
Yeah, it is, it is
I never saw it as a massive deal, to be honest
To somebody else who couldn’t have children...
...I’ve got all the bits to help, so why wouldn’t I help?
As well as Britain, other countries using the altruistic model include...
...Canada and Australia
Supporters say forbidding surrogates to charge direct fees...
...for childbearing reduces the risks of exploitation
However, critics point out...
...the altruistic model is far from a catch-all solution...
...to global surrogacy’s problems
When we look at who’s involved in surrogacy...
...there’s generally lawyers, doctors, nurses...
...and they are all getting paid for their services
The only person who is not being paid for their services...
...is the surrogate, who’s doing, let’s face it, most of the labour
Pun intended
I would like to see minimum and maximum amounts...
...of compensation for surrogacy
Psychological evaluations of all the parties...
...before they embark on surrogacy
There should be mandatory requirements for legal advice
Regulating such a global business is an enormous challenge
And in the often heated debate about this...
...the outcomes of surrogate children can sometimes get forgotten
There is an argument that children...
...born by surrogacy are somehow disadvantaged
The research doesn’t support that
We know that children born via surrogacy...
...do as well as children born in other ways
A recent study suggests that telling surrogate-born children...
...about their origins early in life can help
7% of mothers who did this before their child turned seven...
...reported problems in family relationships...
...compared with 22% who disclosed after the age of seven
So the aim is to hear your views on the surrogacy law
At the University of Leicester, in Britain
Dr Katherine Wade and her colleagues have analysed...
...children’s views on surrogacy laws
They gathered quantitative and qualitative information...
...by talking to children born through surrogacy
We wanted to stop this process of always making assumptions...
...about how children might feel...
...and actually ask them how they do feel
This is a simulation of the team’s focus-group research
Should children born through surrogacy be told that they were...
...born this way?
I put yes, you can discover a new part about yourself
It’s good to know early because if you find out...
...you could get a bit angry at your parents for not telling you
Be wondering why you weren’t told...
...and wondering if there was something wrong...
...with it
In many countries, including Britain...
...you can usually only find out the identities of your egg and sperm donors...
...but not, in most cases, your surrogate
Should children born...
...through surrogacy know who their surrogate was?
Yes, because you could be related to them
There’s no reason to not know
It’s just creating mysteries, it’s just creating a problem
We have our surrogate in our lives...
...and it’s nice to have them around
It’s like a little bit of an extended family
Although circumstances are different for individuals...
...this information can help each to develop what is termed...
...their narrative identity
People are forming integrated life stories throughout their life
It means that you should try to disclose...
...this information to children throughout their childhood
Katherine and her team’s research...
...has fed into forthcoming reforms to laws in Britain
This will include a mandatory register...
...where from the age of 16...
...you can trace nearly everything about your genetic origins...
...from your surrogate to overseas donors
Some states in Australia have a similar law
That is the gold standard: when children can learn...
...their genetic origin stories
What’s in the best interests of the child...
...is a good starting point for thinking...
...about how to better police the global surrogacy industry
With demand rising rapidly...
...getting surrogacy right matters more than ever
We’re not going to be able to stop surrogacy...
...so let’s instead regulate it so that it is...
...a world-class system that respects the rights...
...of all parties who are involved in it
Hi I’m Mian Ridge a correspondent on The Economist’s Britain desk
If you’d like to read more about surrogacy, please click on the link
And if you’d like to watch more of our Now & Next series...
...please click on the other link
Thanks for watching and please don’t forget to subscribe